but Marcus and I
um
we're going to start trying to have a
baby we're trying to have a baby
that's amazing yes you two are going to
love being parents it is
the thing that has ever
even believe how different Our Lives
are like grown up
settled down
we're so boring I don't even recognize
us anymore I mean look at me never
thought I was gonna be one of those
overprotective helicopter dads but
that baby is all I think about he's
obsessed I don't mean to alarm you but I
just found this crawling under our table
I believe it's yours
he's crawling
out of geez amazing you're the most
amazing baby in the whole world we love
you Marcus
[Music]